bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france jean
terlon je commence avec vous comment
est-ce que vous accueillez cette annonce
de bruno le maire est ce que vous
craignez de ne plus être aidées
prochainement même si le ministre de
l'économie promet des aides sectorielles
maintenu au cas par cas
à écouter non las il n'ya pas aucune
surprise c'était prévu il est normal que
quand l'économie redémarre que quoi
qu'il en coûte s'arrête en est on n'a
pas pour fonction d dessus mentionné
sans arrêt il y aura du cas par cas
évidemment il y aura des saumons des
situations différentes et
le ministre bruno le maire s'est
toujours engagé à tenir ses engagements
dont chaos depuis de raisons que ça
change et il est normal que le led qui a
été obtenue est nécessaire pour éviter
des dépôts de bilan en rafale a été été
bienvenu et c'était très bien mais il
est normal que ça s'arrête à philippe
béchade d'un côté il ya ceux qui disent
qu'il n'ya plus d'argent et que la dette
s'alourdit de l'autre il ya les
partisans d'un état providence où se
situe le juste milieu
parce que le débat
le coin puis dans le foot c'est le no
limit en fait en termes d'endettement et
la france
c'est rajouter probablement 350
milliards à l'espace 18 mois ces 350
milliards ne les avions pas ils sont
donc été littéralement imprimées c'est
pour les financiers ça s'appelle de
l'argent à gien tout simplement c'est
une inscription numérique la banque
centrale appuyez sur sur le clic droit
de la souris et mai 9 0 et on peut
rajouter comme ça autant de milliards
qu'on veut et le problème c'est qu'un
jour un jour il faut rembourser alors on
nous promet que c'est pas pour tout de
suite
que la croissance y pourvoit très bien
alors maintenant il reste à en
convaincre nos créanciers des créanciers
de la france détienne un public 50% de
la dette doit tout de même qu'en
l'espace de 18 mois on est passé d'un
endettement de 95 96 % à 120 en libye
actuellement 117 les à la fin d'année on
sera enfin arrivé à assange a donc le
problème c'est que on continue de nous
prêter de l'argent à très bas coût car
c'est le cas en ce moment puisque sur
trois mois on emprunte à - 0 70 ans
qu'on paie la france pour emprunter et
même sur dix ans on en croit encore à
moi 0 17e - 0-15
une semaine donc pour l'instant tout va
bien la confiance est là mais il
faudrait pas que cette confiance s'érode
et évidemment il ya une cohérence dans
le discours tenu par monsieur bruno le
maire en direct de longchamp cette
atonie ville qui nous dit avec une
croissance à 6 % un soutien pour jouer
vous poser cette croissance à 6 %
philippe béchade réaliste ou un topic
alors il ya forcément un effet
rattrapage puisque la france a pris
beaucoup de retard aux premier et
deuxième trimestres alors on s'est
débattue et que toutes les données pour
arriver à ne pas extraire un chiffre
négatif sur le premier trimestre sur le
deuxième trimestre on est à + 0 9 bon ça
ça se compare avait plus de courses en
allemagne + 3 en suisse donc nous on va
évidemment se rattraper un petit peu
reste à savoir si ce rythme va pouvoir
être maintenu poursuit jusqu'à la fin de
l'année alors + 6 % dans un concert
international de croissance mondiale qui
elle aussi appelé zine ray mais 6% on se
dit pourquoi ne ferions nous pas aussi
bien que nous vrai ça etc sauf que
monsieur le maire à longchamp est au
milieu des patrons du medef qui sont des
patrons de multinationales et c'est vrai
qu'à l'international ça marche très fort
et que nos multinationales dégage des
bénéfices comme jamais dans tout paris
afin de retrouver les niveaux pré
pandémique donc si on se fie à la
conjoncture globale on peut penser que
tout va très bien sûr la conjoncture
strictement domestique j'ai un peu plus
de doute voilà
vous a plu jean tellement je me tourne
vers vous par rapport à ce que vient de
dire philippe béchade il a parlé des
grands groupes
est ce qu'il ya une dichotomie justement
entre les grands groupes et les petits
entrepreneurs comme vous restaurateurs
écouter les skis via des dits très
intéressant c'est vrai que ne sait pas
ne faisant pas partie les caps 40 donc
forcément on écoute ça avec une oreille
nous ne la problématique c'est
premièrement il faut quand même
être conscient qu'on a eu un côté un
fonds de solidarité qui est venu aider à
éviter aux restaurateurs et surtout leur
permettre de pouvoir redémarrer quand le
redémarrage a eu lieu mais leurs
problèmes de l'art de nos secteurs c'est
les emprunts que l'on attende c'est à
dire les prêts garantis par l'état
s'appelle dpe qui à partir de marcy pour
les produits vont être dans l'obligation
de rembourser après avoir eu un décalage
d'un an de remboursement donc là on va
se rendre compte malheureusement des
difficultés qui risque d'y avoir de
rembourser après il n'est pas une aide
mais qui était un prêt nous a permis
d'éviter alors c'était surtout pour le
premier confinement le deuxième
confinement est pas pu améliorer ce
fonds que ce prêt garanti par l'état et
donc ça c'est là que le réveil du
rembourser remboursement des prêts
garantis par l'état va se faire
ressentir et on ne sait pas trop de quel
pas dire parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que pas sanitaires à utilité pour la
vaccination le problème c'est qu'ils
freinent quand même la fréquentation des
tirs même si techniquement ça se passe
très bien et que les consommateurs sont
favorables en tant que consommateurs ils
ont une salle sécurisée du personnel
sécurisé mais il ya quand même de 40
sont pas qu'ils n'ont pas de façade père
il ya forcément un frein donc tout ça
mis bout à bout leur problème c'est
l'emploi dans la restauration
le manque de personnel et puis là au
moment où la poussée des prix garantis
par l'état
justement jean talon le 30 août donc
c'est très tôt c'est lundi bruno le
maire va recevoir les représentants des
secteurs en difficulté dont le vôtre
et
vous appelez un grenelle de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie qu'est ce
que vous allez dire au ministre de
l'économie lundi qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce rendez vous concrètement
tout le monde va s'envoyer des chiffres
ceux du ministère les d'autres puisque
nous on a au sein du midd enquête a été
menée auprès de quelque 4000
professionnels ont répondu pour savoir à
peu près comment valoriser leur valeur
économique dans leurs établissements
c'est à dire que 80% des entreprises non
pas un pourcentage de baisse mais quel
point considérant les entreprises qui
ont répondu sur les 4010 avant d avoir
une baisse du chiffre d'affaires
pointent si on est en train de mettre ça
à plat donc qu'il soit dessus vous avez
évoqué un grenelle de l'art est de là
dans le secteur c'est vrai qu'on aurait
bien besoin parce que le pigment a
provoqué beaucoup d beaucoup de dégâts
en terme de deux salariés
et qui ont beaucoup de mal à me mets un
grenelle pour quelle mesure au final
sortir le carnet de chèques
non non non le carnet de chèques ont
déjà sorti une ligne ressortiront paille
c'est bien normal et monsieur a raison
on va pas le coupé à
prendre de l'argent ou annuler d'offrir
de l'argent pour pour survivre le but
d'une entreprise c'est de vivre par
elle-même et nous sommes des chefs
d'entreprises et on n'a jamais eu par
habitude d'être subventionné à moins que
nos restaurants domaine des lieux de
fonction publique mais je crois pas mais
on n'est pas on n'est pas là vous
partagez ce qu'a dit geoffroy roux de
bézieux tout à l'heure le président du
medef aux côtés de bruno le maire il a
dit nous ne sommes pas des entrepreneurs
pour vivre des aides de l'état il est
temps que l'état revienne à sa juste
place
absolument il a raison
philippe béchade pour pour revenir à
tout ça
cette décision du gouvernement
est-ce qu'elles risquent pas d'engendrer
un rebond des fermetures
d'établissements et à terme de freiner
la croissance économique
moi j'ai bien écouté bruno le maire donc
il a délivré un message qui peut
paraître importante c'est que le pass
sanitaires
il est là pour encore longtemps pour
plusieurs mois ra qu'ils ont je me pose
c'est qu'est ce qu'on s'est fixé comme
but strictement sanitaires est-ce que
avec le pass à lithaire on a voulu
freiner la propagation du virus parce
qu'on avait constaté des clusters dans
les restaurants dans les salles de sport
dans les stades je ne sais pas on ne
s'est pas fixé d'objectif pour le pass
sanitaires dont on ne sait pas s'il sera
levé parce qu'on a atteint un objectif
qui est par exemple de ramener le taux
de reproduction du virus à à moins de 1%
le taux d'incidence a à moins de 2 05 je
ne sais pas du tout aujourd'hui où est
ce qu'on va donc effectivement
d'affaires que le gouvernement
éclaircisse ça et puis c'est quand même
assez
frappant de constater que le pass
solitaire touche d'abord les activités
de loisirs sell qui finalement frustre
le plus les consommateurs donc on
comprend bien l'intention qui est de se
servir de ce levier pour pousser à la
vaccination mais la question c'est
est-ce que
interdire par exemple les terrasses à
des gens qui n'ont pas de passes
potentiellement contaminés est-ce que ça
met plus en sécurité les gens qui
seraient à l'intérieur des restaurants
et qui sont de double vacciner mais qui
sont aujourd'hui également reconnu comme
potentiellement contaminés enfin il ya
beaucoup de choses qui nous interroge et
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
fait que les entrepreneurs ne sont pas
là pour être des assistés mais il n'y a
rien à vous il n'ya rien à voir entre un
goût plus 4 40 tirs accès aux marchés de
capitaux qui peut faire autant de levée
de fonds qu'il veut puisque derrière
c'est quand même la banque centrale qui
achètent les émissions obligataires se
rappelle des 16 milliards émis par lvmh
pour acheter de tiffany et c'est
finalement au bout du compte la banque
centrale
européenne qui en a acheté pratiquement
la moitié alors qu'un restaurateur un
exploitant de salles de sport il n'a que
son banquier en face de lui et son
banquier lui et ne le payent pas pour
emprunter comme un groupe du cac 40 qui
est noté triple triple à donc on est
vraiment là face à un autre souci qui
n'est qu' il est fort quand même que les
banques continuent d'aider toutes les
professions qui aujourd'hui voit une
forte baisse de leur chiffre d'affaires
et qui les aident sur sur le long terme
si le gouvernement lui ne le fait plus
mais on va forcément tomber face à un
mur de la dette à un moment ou un autre
si le
pass n'est pas n'est pas supprimée parce
qu'on ne verra pas revenir la totalité
des clients et puis non seulement il ya
des gens qui sont double vacciner mais
qui ne veut pas présenter le pass pour
des raisons de principe parce que je ne
veux pas être
suivi dans toutes ses activités voilà
donc la question du passé les ailes et
centrale il faut qu'on se fixe quand
même un objectif parce que s'il n'y a
pas d'objectif dans le temps il va
falloir que les restaurateurs puisse
négocier avec leur banquier ainsi un
point de solutions merci philippe
béchade avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef du site la bourse au quotidien je
remercie également jean talon je
rappelle que vous êtes le vice-président
de l'umih l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie pour la secte
le secteur de la restauration ce qui
vous concerne